字幕: Haru Yamaguchi
校正: Hiroko Kawano
小さい頃に書いた卒業文集を見てみると
いつも決まって 同じ職業の
ことを書いていました
[保育園卒園文集]
保育士です
保育園の卒園文集には
「大きくなったら 保育士になりたい」
と書いていました
そして 小学校４年生の時の夢学習の時も
保育士になる道について調べていました
両親や祖父母が 保育園を
経営していることもあり
保育士になるということ自体には
全く抵抗ありませんでした
むしろ 家族に対する漠然とした憧れから
「自分は保育士になるんだ」と心の中で
勝手に決めつけていたのかもしれません
だから 幼い自分なりに
ピアノを習ってみたり
保育園のお手伝いをしてみたり
たくさんのことをやってきました
自分なりに 保育士になるための
努力をしていたんです
でも なんだか保育士を目指すだけじゃ
満足できませんでした
なんだか物足りなかったんです
だから 小学校の時は
習い事を６つ掛け持ちしてみたり
児童会に自ら立候補してみたり
中学受験をやってみたり
本当に色んなことに挑戦してきました
多分きっと自分にはまる何かを
探していたんだと思います
そして そんな私が
今 所属している部活は科学部です
そして 不思議なことに
物理の研究をやっているんです
これは 私が研究発表で使った資料の一部です
これを見て 分かる方 いらっしゃいますか？
あ 顧問の先生ですね
そうです
ほとんどの方が分からないと思います
しかも 「うわ マジかよ？」って
なりますよね
私も最初はそうでした
でも 物理班に入った時から
こんなことが当たり前になって
気付かないうちに日常になってくるんです
さて みなさんは物理 フィジックスに対して
どんなイメージを抱いていますか？
（英語）[物理]
例えば メガネ率が高いとか
話が通じないとか
ずうっと同じ本を読んでいるとか
オタクみたいな人が多いとか
そんなイメージ 抱いていませんか？
私自身も勝手にそんな
イメージを抱いていました
物理をされていらっしゃる方が
いたらごめんなさい
でも 本当に私は
こんなイメージを抱いていたんです
でも 私は小さい時から憧れていた
保育士とは全く違う
科学の道に足を踏み入れることになりました
そして 巷でいう 「リケジョ」
という道を切り開くための起爆剤に
ラッキーなことにも
出会うことができたんです
今 「ラッキー」という言葉を使いました
科学に出会うって
ラッキーだと思いませんか？
思いませんか？
（笑）
多分それはきっと その世界に
まだ目を向けたことがないからです
私は中学校に入った時に
今まで以上に 色んなことに
挑戦しようと思いました
だから 元々興味があった
社会福祉系のボランティアをやってみたり
生徒会に入ってみたり
本当に小学生の時とは
比べものにならないぐらい
もっともっと挑戦をしていったんです
だから 時にはパンクしそうになる時もあって
中学校の三者面談ではいつも
「そろそろ優先順位を決めなさい」
「早くやりたいことを見つけなさい」
って言われていました
でも 毎日が充実してたんです
毎日が本当に楽しかったんです
そんなある中学校３年生の時の夏
先生からこんな提案がありました
「成松 高校の科学部の大会に
同行してみないか」
私 書道部 —
しかも バリバリの文系なんですけど
そんな私が科学部の大会に!?
いや もちろんイエスですよね
こんな性格ですから
「ノー」と言う考えなんか
元々頭になかったですし
そんな美味しい話があるのに
なんで行かないんだって感じで
もちろん 二つ返事でオーケーしました
そして ある大会に
参加することになったんですが
この大会が 私の中に科学という
新しい視点をくれることになったんです
私が通っている学校は 中高一貫校です
でも 私は高校の先輩が
科学の研究をしていること自体
全く知りませんでした
ましてや 科学のその研究の内容なんて
本当にさっぱりでした
でも やっぱり部室に行ってみると
周りを見てみれば やっぱりメガネ率は高いし
振り返って見たら ずうっと同じ本ばっかりを
読んでいる先輩もいるんですね
でも案外 イメージと
違うところがあったんですよ
それは 先輩たちが
おしゃべりが大好きだったことです
中学生の私にも 気さくに
話しかけてくれました
そしてある先輩は
大会会場となる大阪行きの新幹線の中で
私たちのために 「超短期研究集中講座」って
いうのを開いてくれて
何もわからない私たちに
ゼロから研究の内容や
自分の経験について
すごく情熱的に話してくれたんです
そんな姿を見た時
私は驚きにも似た感動を覚えました
「こんな先輩 科学部にいるんだ」って
でも 先輩たちの姿は
こんなもんじゃなかったんです
大会最終日 私たちの研究は
何千人ものお客さんがいるステージの前で
発表することになりました
そしてある先輩が研究発表の最後に
こう言ったんです
「私たちは この研究を
教科書に載せたいです」
「ん？」
ちょっと考えてみても
やっぱり「ん？」ってなるんですよね
「いやいや先輩 それ
ビッグマウス過ぎませんか？」みたいな
なんか「え いや あり得ないでしょ？」って
単純にそう思ったんです
中学生の私なりに
先輩方の研究はすごいっていうことは
分かっているつもりでした
でも 高校生の研究が教科書に載るなんて
想像したこともなかったですし
頭に全くなかったんです
でも 私はこのたった一言
あの時のこの一言に突き動かされて
この日 科学部に入部することを決めました
そして 今年度の物理の教科書の１ページに
宇土高校科学部の研究が
実際に載ってるんです
あの時の まさにあの時のあの一言が
本当に現実のものになったんです
さて そろそろみなさんも
私がこんな風に変わった研究に
少し興味が湧いてきませんか？
「副実像 secondary real images」
これが私たちの研究対象です
副実像についてご存じの方
いらっしゃいますか？
ほとんどいらっしゃらないですよね
というのも この副実像は
宇土高校の先輩方が初めて発見されて
その時に定義したものだからです
こちらをご覧ください
これは光がどのように進むかを
光路図としてあらわしたものです
光源から出た光が 凸レンズで曲げられて
反対側に実像が結像します
でも これは中学校の範囲で習う範囲で
従来知られている実像です
しかし これとは別に
レンズの前方と後方に
あと２つ現れている小さな倒立像を
先輩方が発見されました
そして それらを「副実像」
と名付けられたんです
これらの副実像は
このように 光がレンズの中に入って
内部反射をすることによって結像しています
そして これこそがいわゆる心霊現象[が]
どのように撮られているのかという
メカニズムを解明したり
昆虫の単眼がどのような世界を見ているか
というものを表す糸口になったんです
それではここで みなさんで
心霊写真を撮ってみましょう
私が持っているのが 平面LEDライトです
そして これに光をつけると
これが光源になります
もしみなさんの中で
ケータイ、iPhoneやXperiaを
持っていらっしゃる方がいたら
私の方にカメラを
向けてもらってもいいですか？
なんだか肉眼では見えないけど
レンズの中に浮いている
不思議な光はないですか？
見つけられましたか？
それこそが副実像です
みなさん どんな像が映っていますか？
くまモンの像
見えますか？
今回 ご用意したのは
くまモンの像をご用意してみました
もし ケータイを持って
いらっしゃらない方がいらっしゃったら
あちらのスクリーンをご覧ください
あそこに出ている副実像は
今 会場の中のカメラで
作り出されている副実像です
はい
大丈夫でしょうか？
はい ありがとうございます
そして この副実像が
どのように心霊写真として
現れているかをご説明します
私たちは被写体に向かって
いつもカメラを向けていますよね？
で その時に 先ほどの実像のように
被写体から出た光が レンズを通して
スクリーン上に結像します
ですが 先ほどの光路図のように
副実像は レンズのすぐ後方にも現れるんです
そして カメラのピントを調整するためなどに
レンズとスクリーンの距離が近くなった時
この後方の副実像が画面上に現れる
つまりスクリーンに載る
よって心霊写真が作られているんです
これで 一部の心霊写真は
証明することができます
そして私たちはこの研究を
生物分野に応用させました
というのも ある学会で
「人間の目でも副実像は見えますか？」
というご質問をいただいたからです
回答からお答えすると 見ることはできません
じゃあ 人間の目によく似た構造を持つ
昆虫の単眼はどうだろう？
そういった疑問から 私たちはこの研究に
昆虫の単眼を使いました
そして 今回対象にした昆虫は
こちらの３つです
アブラゼミ、オオスズメバチ
トノサマバッタの３種を使いました
そして ここで単眼とは何かをご説明します
昆虫は よく見る —
人間の目のような大きなものを２つ
「複眼」というものを持っています
しかし それとは別に頭の上部の方に
レンズ眼でできている
「単眼」というものがあります
このスライドの中では
赤い丸で囲んである部分が単眼です
そして私たちは 採取した昆虫を
マイナス60℃で冷凍し
凍結ミクロトームと呼ばれる機器を用いて
10㎛ずつスライスしていきました
それを染色液で染色し
レンズがどれだけ曲がっているか
といった「曲率半径」
レンズの厚み
そして網膜までの位置を特定します
これらのデータを以前導出していた
式に代入することによって
そして 屈折率 n を考慮することによって
昆虫の単眼において どこに副実像が
現れているのかというものを導出しました
今回は オオスズメバチの
単眼モデルを使ってご説明します
左側に見える白いものが
オオスズメバチの単眼です
そして 丸くなっている部分が網膜です
実は 昆虫は遠視の状態
つまり人間で言うと
老眼のような状態なんです
だから 昆虫の単眼の中では
実像は 網膜からもっともっと
遠いところに結像しています
ですが 今回の調査によって
副実像は 実像よりもより網膜に近い位置に
結像していることが分かりました
そして この結果は
アブラゼミ、トノサマバッタなどの
他の全ての昆虫においても
主実像より網膜に近い位置に
副実像が出現していることが分かりました
このことから 私たちは
昆虫が副実像を見ている可能性を
示唆することができたんです
そしてこの研究は 次のような例に
応用することができます
例えば 広角レンズに応用できるんです
副実像は より広い範囲で
現れることができます
だから より広範囲を捉える
監視カメラであったり
天体の動きを観測する装置に
応用することが考えられています
これが 私たちの研究です
この研究をここまで持ってくるのに６年半
22名の生徒 そして顧問の先生が
何度も何度も挑戦を積み重ねてきました
そして私たちはこの成果を持って
今年の５月 アメリカの
ピッツバーグで行われた
Intel ISEF（インテル・アイセフ）
という大会に参加してきました
Intel ISEFとは
「国際学生科学技術フェア 」という大会で
Society for Science & the Public
というところが主催しています
毎年５月にアメリカの都市で開催されており
今回の2018年度大会は
81の国や地域から
1792名の学生が参加しました
賞金総額400万ドル以上
スポンサーが 60以上もつく
まさに世界規模の大会です
そこで 私たちは
物理・天文学部門に出展しました
ISEFでは 日本の大会とは少し異なり
「その研究は社会のためにどう役に立つの？」
「どれぐらいのお金を生み出せるの？」
といった工業的な質問が
たくさん飛び交いました
私たちの研究は基礎研究に入るので
そういった質問に答えるのは
少し難しかったですが
宇土高校から行った
３人のみんなで一緒に頑張って
なんとか その質問を
乗り切ることができました
そして ４位という —
グランドアワード４位
物理天文学部で４位という
素晴らしい成績を得ることができました
表彰式で名前を呼ばれた時
私がステージの上から見たあの景色は
きっと私は 一生
忘れることができないと思います
だから そんなアメリカの舞台に
もう一度立ちたいと思ったんです
小さい時から保育士になるのが夢でした
そして中３の夏に 科学に目覚めました
その２つを学べる環境が
アメリカにはあります
そしてもう１つ
私にはやらなければならないことがあるんです
ISEFに参加すると
このような金のメダルをもらえます
でも —
そして この金のメダルを左胸に掲げて
生徒たちは審査に臨みます
でも周りを見てみると 少し違ったんです
ISEFには ４年連続で
参加している生徒がたくさんいます
今回 私たちが参加した大会でも
１位の優勝をしたところは
優勝した オーストラリアの学生は
左胸にたくさんのメダルをつけていました
そして 今回のISEFにアメリカに次いで
生徒を送り込んできたのは
韓国の47名です
中国や台湾の台頭も見られます
しかし 日本の学生は
今回 23名しか参加していません
しかもほとんどが
１回しか参加できないんです
こんなことで 科学の世界で
戦っていけるんでしょうか？
若者の時点で負けていて いいんでしょうか？
だから私は 後輩たちに何度も何度も
チャレンジできる環境を作りたいんです
そして私たちのリベンジをして欲しいんです
だから私はアメリカの大学で
教育政策と科学を学びたいと思っています
こう言うと みなさんには
ビッグマウスに見えるかもしれません
でも 私はそれでいいんです
何故なら 私が中３の時 憧れていた先輩も
私にはビッグマウスに見えました
でも 彼女の夢は実際に叶ったんですから
ありがとうございました
（拍手）